[Music]
let's go to sandy in grand rapids
michigan what's up sandy
hi say john how are you i'm so good how
about you
good thank you so what's up
um i wanted to ask you um how can i deal
with the guilt that i carry uh as a
child of immigrants
who unpack that for me that one's a good
one
yeah so my parents fled the middle east
once the wars started
and after years of moving around we
finally came to america as refugees back
when i was about eight years old how
long ago is that 10 years ago 15 years
ago um about 13 13. okay
oh can i guess here can i guess
sure
so
you how old you were 13 when you moved
here
i i was eight when i said oh you said
that okay so
you get dropped into an american school
and there's a
you got trapped between cultures is that
right
100 yes and then
parents are still in fight or flight
because their home was taken from them
and the easiest thing someone in a fight
or flight can do is to default hardcore
to what you know and what is safe and
what is safe is
this is the way we do it because this is
how we have always done it
you're spot on and then you're an
immigrant student who now wants to go to
college if you're not are you in college
or through
i am in college my last year oh and now
you're tortured by i love the idea in
america you can kind of just do whatever
you want to whenever you want to however
you want to
and i also love and want to honor my
parents and oh crap what i do now
is that right you got it you got it
exactly kelly we should start a radio
show it's incredible
uh hey um so iraq is that right
yes okay what um
what religious sect
uh christian okay okay
so
oh man
how fun is that
i've bet finding a church is a hoot is
that has that just been a blast
holy smokes
so how do you deal with how do you deal
with the guilt um tell me more about
that
well you know growing up i heard all
these awful stories about what they've
been through and then hearing comments
like we get out so much to give you and
you know your siblings a better life
so that's you know all that pressure
um and like you said they have very
strict views and they're very stuck on
their old ways
so you know i did the right thing by
like going to college and getting
education getting like a stable
corporate job doing all that kind of
stuff
um and most of it is signed but what's
really hard for me has been when i don't
agree on like certain topics and there
are certain views um like not moving
down until i'm married no matter how old
that is
um dating only within the community the
same religion same you know country
um and then like being trained from
birth as a girl to take care of the
house
cook and clean that kind of thing while
my brothers you know got to sit around
and have fun yeah just things like that
just things like that that was the most
incredibly dismissive just like just
things like that like my
like my
gender and my work ethic and my
religious heritage and my my romantic
life just little things like that
oh man that's so hard so hard
um
wow and so you're about to graduate and
this is about to get real for you do you
live at home now
i do okay
and do you enjoy living at home or is it
are you dying a slow miserable death
of the latter okay
and walk me through
like just if for the average american
listener who doesn't understand this
it feels like a simple answer and by the
way i want you to know
um i've worked with a number of
international students and immigrant
students over the years and so your
journey is one i've heard a lot
um but i did contact kelly let me know
that this call's coming so i did contact
two of my buddies who are professors who
study this intercultural competence it's
that's a challenge for folks like you
who are caught between two two worlds
um and that's so hard um so
the
walk an average american listener
through because it seems like we'll just
move out of the house dude
like
when you hear something like that your
buddy in school just like well just move
out walk somebody through what that
actually would mean for you
um
that would mean i would bring so much
shame to my family i wouldn't hear the
end of it um most likely if i were to do
that then my sister will kind of get
like a bad reputation and like she won't
get married
i'll probably kind of be shunned from
the community
just you know
things like that
besides shame and shumming i mean
shame and shunning what else sandy
lots of anger they probably will not
talk to me for
years if not if you notice ever
um i probably won't get any support with
that
the financial support
right yeah so or emotional mental yeah
all of it yeah so it's it's it's kind of
it's an opt-in or opt completely out huh
exactly yeah
so what are a couple of things that you
love
about the your parents culture your
culture that your parents are really
holding on to tightly what's a couple
things you love
the support from family is pretty major
you won't really ever be in need
financially or like that when you have
them
without any question they'll be there to
help you
and
even though you know we moved out from
home um they kind of built a new home
here the
the culture definitely came with them
and the people are still kind of
together they help each other out is
there a small iraqi community that still
hangs out
yeah okay yeah and then there's moms and
dads talk about who's going to marry who
and when and all that
yep
so
i'm gonna give you a complex answer okay
and here's here's why it's complex
i don't feel qualified to give you an
answer that's not gonna be heavily
directed by
the fact that i'm like
an american male
does that make sense
so the easy answer is
um
at the end of the day you have to make a
choice
and at the end of the day you know
there's not an easy exit strategy and
there's not an easy acceptance strategy
and
at the end of the day it's simple to be
like well you just got to move on cut
your ties and go
and whoa
you're talking hundreds if not thousands
of years of this is how and why we love
one another it's different right it's
it's hard and it's messy
and so
the reality is you're gonna have to make
a choice
i i don't feel comfortable telling you
what here's what i think your choice
should be
what i will tell you is
here are some broad parameters
uh or some broad things to think through
and again there's a couple of my buddies
here researchers that walk me through
this
um
the first one is no matter what you do
make peace with conflict because it's
gonna come
there's not a choice you make that
doesn't come with conflict here whether
it's internal or whether it's external
so if you make peace with conflict it's
often not
you can hold it in your soul better
meaning
it's people that go to the gym to work
out that realize working out's hard and
they quit
it's those that know working out's
really hard and that's why i'm going
that do really well does that make sense
yeah so expect that conflict
especially in a family system where
somebody decides they're going to change
the rules of the system
um
has there been any sort of what i would
call family concession meaning is there
a few things that they don't really like
to admit but that they've americanized
yeah um but i feel like it's more so
with the boys in the family
you know them going out them dating them
that kind of thing and it's definitely
just around the girls
so is there somebody in your family
system um is it is it a highly paternal
system like you don't ask questions you
just say yes sir and y'all move on
yeah or is there a conversation you can
have with mom or with that is there a is
there that level of
um
just mutual respect
um i can definitely have a chromosome
with my dad um it at the end of it it
does kind of end up in that hole like
i'm the dad see what i do kind of thing
but he will listen out
um just he just kind of tells me that
it's out of his control and that's just
how the society is that's just how the
community is and i have to just live
with it basically
so he really passes the buck on to not
this is what i say but sorry this is
just the world we live in
and that's just kind of where that is
so let me ask you a hard question i know
you've thought about it what do you want
to do
what do you want to do
you asked me how to deal with guilt
that that
provides a hint that you may just be
thinking of graduating and going to
getting your own place and figuring this
thing out
that has definitely been my
thought for a while and i'll i'll think
it and then you know with any anger
like we'll fuel it and then that kind of
goes away and then the guilt comes in oh
they gave up so much i shouldn't do that
um but i don't think i can see myself
being happy if i do stay so what i will
tell you is guilt will ultimately
kill you
from the inside out
it'll melt your spirit and it will
literally eat you physiologically
because
do what
i'm definitely feeling that
there you go
and so what i will tell you is
either
choose to
choose to live into your culture
or choose to
chart your new path
and you're going to feel sad it's gonna
be chaotic there's gonna be conflict
either way you go
but if you lean into and let guilt
become the the the blood that circulates
through your veins
man that's gonna be that's gonna just
it's gonna destroy you from inside out
my hope and dream would be
that you sit down with your dad and say
um i am so grateful for the heritage i'm
so grateful for the culture i'm so
grateful for the community and
i feel like i need to go find myself
and my hope and prayer for me and my
family
is that you all don't respond to my
choice
by ending our relationship and cutting
me off
because here's the other the other side
of choice you can't control other
people's response
and so whatever choice you make
in or out
they get to choose their response and so
if they choose to cut you off if they
choose to withdraw all support if they
choose to
shame you and whatever whatever they
choose to do
um
whatever that community chooses to do
that's their response to you not the
other way around does that make sense
yeah
and so you said what are you studying
accounting
and what do you want to do when you grow
up an accountant or you want to work for
a company just doing books and things
um i'm currently working for a company
doing that um the hope is yeah get a
master's degree and become an accountant
okay
so where do you want to do that
what do i do accounting
where are you set where
i haven't thought that far to be honest
with you
so do this get a friend or two friends
and think about
what tomorrow could look like go one
year go three years down the road
imagine yourself done with grad school
imagine yourself
walking across the stage
and then what and i want you to be
really clear about what a picture of
then what looks like what state are you
living in what does your house look like
what does your home look like what do
your friends and community look like
paint that picture
because i want you to walk towards
something whatever you do not run from
something i want you to if you're going
to lean into
this like you know what i need to go
back home until i'm married that's the
culture that's our that's our
um national
culture that's our religious culture
that's the heritage
um i'm gonna honor my family that way
and i'm gonna honor myself that way by
honoring my family that whatever you
choose to do
i'm gonna go towards that or
nope this is the part where i carve my
own path i'm going to choose that i'm
going to lean into it and here's what
it's going to look like
and that way you're walking towards
something and you're not
untethered and unanchored because
there's going to be conflict when you
disrupt the system
but my recommendation is sit down with
that sounds like he's an awesome guy
that would listen to you and sit down
and say i know these things and
i've got to chart my own path i've got
to take my own course
and i hope that you won't choose that
that means
that we're done
hope that you choose not to
cut me off to shame me to disconnect
from me but you choose you can be
disappointed you can say that's not the
path i would have chosen but that's my
girl she's brilliant she's accomplished
and we're gonna support her even if we
have to grit our teeth
and he may say sorry that's out of my
control it's out of my hands
and then he's made his decision
but at the end of the day um i can't
speak into it for you i can't tell you
what i think you should do or here's
what i would do because i don't know
i can know i've made different choices
than my parents probably would have
picked for me um but i also know that um
they trained me from a young boy to man
here's a machete here's how this works
you go carve you on path and so i was
blessed and fortunate that way
um
thank you so so much for the call here's
what i would love i would love to know
how that conversation goes if you'll
circle back to us and let us know how it
goes
um
i always say this
choose guilt not resentment
if you're gonna go home and you're to
live in ash and you're going to
just smolder from the inside out and
that's going to that's going to burn
down your relationships and your
friendships and your community
connections and your faith and your
relationship with your mom your dad and
your brothers
choose guilt over resentment every time
and don't let people beat you up for we
chose we did this and i want to say like
well y'all chose that
and be grateful too it's a hard hard row
you're walking expect conflict expect
discomfort get some people that are to
walk it with you
and go towards something not away from
it